are you seeing anybody right now no
single what's your dating what what's
what's the vibe oh this guy's a player
dog um I I yeah I've been pretty much
just uh I would say I guess casually
dating I've been basically touring for
two years like the special just ended
and I just finished the tour at the
Beacon Theater in New York it was like
the last shows and so um and now I'm
doing the promo Run for the special and
then it's like I'm taking some time off
so it's just kind of weird to try and
date and one where you when you don't
live
anywhere I can't see anybody there's
defin there's there's there's there's
women that I have like I've talked about
this before but it's like um I dated
girls in open relationships because it's
like a way to kind of get intimacy where
it's like you are friends you do get to
hook up but it doesn't feel like no
you're being everyone's like honest
about what's going on where it's like
instead of you know one night stands or
having kind of some weird somebody you
live in a different City and you don't
keep up with it you don't want to hurt
anybody's feelings so it's like dating a
girl in like an open relationship who's
like engaged and like happy and just
wants to have a nice little weekend
whenever I'm in town that's cool you you
guys are in an open relationship or
she's in one no she's in one I'm popping
in and you don't ever find that when you
get into those relationships with uh
women in open relationships that it ever
gets messy or you're just not aware or
you kind of just that out yeah I think I
think it it's it hasn't because it's
pretty clear what I'm up to you I mean
I'm I'm super they don't expect anything
from me you know what I mean I'm like a
because girls in open relationships it's
like there's an honesty to it where it's
like whereas if you just had a fling
with somebody on a weekend they might
expect something more but if she's
already like with who she wants to be
with and they have their own Arrangement
and you just get to get you don't get
certain things from that the stuff that
I desire but he doesn't need it yet I
think he does want it though eventually
yeah I want to I I was in a
relationship uh I guess two or three
years ago and I haven't been in one
since and so I want to and so when I
when I am like stable again when I'm in
a place I'm going to be in New York for
you know six months or whatever uh I'm
taking a lot of time off the road and
just trying to be a human being um yeah
I'll give it a go you know I'll give it
a whirl see the I I I have to
say I have to because anyway so one
night I was in a different town yeah and
um you I met this girl we met had sexy
sex right at 5: in the morning um she
just wakes me up and she's fully clothed
and she looks at she goes I'm leaving
and I go okay bye right yeah and she
goes like she I felt like she wanted
more right I was like look at her go get
the [__] out of
here were you already asleep I was half
asleep half not but then I woke up
feeling how I I just felt that whole
interaction to be um full of emptiness
mhm and pointlessness yeah right and I'm
like I don't think I mean as a young man
when you do stuff like that it's like
yeah I got late right but as you get I'm
52 years old it just becomes like not it
just like pointless and like almost
gross and empty yeah right and it's like
I just and I realized it's not about the
sexual thing it's I need I'm I'm longing
for
something deeper you know what I mean
and um you know and what I'm telling you
is that don't don't you long that as
well yeah but it's also cool to you know
get a couple nuts off and see a bunch of
different types of what kind of noises
do you make when I when I bus I'm a
pretty I don't know I don't know that
I'm very I I'll grunt I suppose I I
haven't really thought about it I mean
do you ever quiet do I ever quiet are
you
quiet what do you mean I do quiet style
like when I come I purposely don't say
anything some kind of I'll just yeah
I'll look in the eyes assassin thing
I'll
go like you're committing sepu yeah
yeah yeah and they're always like you
know I mean like they look at me like
what the [__] is happening yeah exactly
52y old man no old and fat NE neither of
us can do it neither one of us can I
can't be quietly coming people I did
they'll think I'm having a heart attack
be like oh [__] he's about to die inside
of me so you do make a noise I make it
who doesn't
make what is I guess I don't really
particularly want
to I would have to think about it no
because I think about like when I make
the noise I think about wow that's an
I've never made that noise anywhere in
civilized society that's the good thing
that's the cool thing about it you get
to be an animal basic right yeah and
that's why I also don't want to talk
like I could talk if I'm in the zone but
I like just you just you're just like
yeah this is about coming everyone's
having oh now I'm now I got stop you're
trying to get me to moaned [__] 30
seconds ago all right I'm sorry no but
do do you feel empty afterwards or no it
depends I don't know yeah yeah sometimes
yeah sure sometimes it is pathological
sometimes you're it's taking the the
place of uh of you know of um like just
being